d'ailleurs je me demandant mon petit à
petit au début pour pourquoi faire non
pas du tout alors moi certainement pas
non moi je suis assez heureux comme ça
peut vraiment pas du tout pourquoi je
serai ailleurs en europe que comme vous
dites d'ailleurs pourquoi demain pour
avoir un mot de plus que je pourrai pas
me prononcer d'ailleurs d'ailleurs
écouté je vous dis entre patrese entrera
temps pèse entre nous qu'est ce que
c'est que le qu'est ce que c'est que le
bonheur voulez-vous me dire non mais
c'est vrai vous pensez peut-être que moi
c'est toutefois compliquée vous me direz
c'est peut-être une promesse que ce fait
l'esprit de moi que ce fait l'esprit
moyenne et ne tenait jamais jamais
jamais une tonnerre et je comptais
dessus ah non pour faire mon bonheur ça
on est heureux on est heureux toujours
contre quelqu'un c'est pas vrai ça vous
devrez composer le coeur on est heureux
de ce qu'on n'a pas on cherche toujours
ce qu'on n'a pas d'ailleurs un manteau
de fourrure par exemple unsa chevaux
l'algérie chevaux un col de fourrure
d'un manteau en fourrure à sa sage sage
car marquer et c'est à ce moment là que
le malheur comment madame quand vous
l'avez oui le malheur le malheur le
malheur le malheur arrive
le malheur commence pourquoi
commence-t-il
parce que le temps le temps arrive la
pendue à aa ah si on pouvait arrêter le
temps mais justement on ne peut pas
avancer par le temps qui passe c'est
nous non non le bonheur c'est trop de
souci ça ccct on n'est jamais tranquille
mais c'est trop fragile et du cristal ça
vous puissez pas ça seulement
mais le bonheur essayait de dire le
bonheur soit sans avoir peur ça ça
explose comme une explosion un tueur
helmand et ça se prolonge bonheur
bonheur non plus ça me fait peur non non
non moi moi moi n'ont jamais là
maintenant alors ça si vous voulez
vraiment que je vous dise la vérité je
vous le dirai il n'y a pas de bonheur
sans cerutti quai et c'est là ce sens et
que 10 ray cyrus et tout ça sans la
certitude la permanence voilà ce qui
fait le bonheur c'est la permanence si
vous voulez être heureux faites comme
moi moi je suis pessimiste à sa demande
du boulot ça se passe comme ça faut y
penser
faut être inventif faut être imaginatif
ça
tous les joueurs moi j'avance du malheur
le plus neuf le plus invraisemblable je
me dis bon maintien par exemple
aujourd'hui je me disais c'est pas la
peine que j'y aille
il y aura pas de métro je pourrais pas
venir y aura la grève c'est pas vrai
c'est demain aa je me disais mais il est
aux mains de demain il va pleuvoir et
c'est pas du tout je suis regarde sur le
carreau c'est des perles de perles et
qui coûte tout le long des vitres et
puis non je me dit une femme
pourquoi faire pour être pompée elle m'a
jamais trompé comme l'a toujours dit ah
ah non non non non et tous les jours
tous les jours croyez moi tous les jours
j'avais avant un truc nouveau un truc
sensationnel votre mortelle de me serais
en bouillie chambilly par un camion le
ma femme aura des malheurs que de sa vie
et à l'heure à 10 millions de dettes on
mourra qu'à 110 ans
[Rires]
la vie ne peux plus me suivre c'est moi
le plus fort rien viennent peu plus de
surprendre
tenez plus vous serez pessimiste si vous
suivez ma leçon
plus vous serez heureux rêver le pire ce
soir et je vous promets demain des
matins triomphant émerveillé dans la
joie et puis alors personne ne pourra
vous l'apprendre celle là nick and i ni
khrouchtchev eureka 2h15 eux eureka le
bonheur voilà le bonheur c'est de bien
jouer même si on n'a pas de jeu à moi de
donner c'est ça le bonheur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]